hello everyone and welcome to game four
of the uh spectacular match magnus cross
and versus levon arenan from round three
of the ftx crypto cup uh it's uh really
really important for lavon to win this
one because as you've seen magnus won
the first game he played that fancy b5
move against lavon's london system then
the next two games ended in a draw and
now levon is in a must-win situation and
for this special occasion he chooses uh
counter magnus with the king's indian
defense which always ends up by someone
sacrificing something and everything is
just all over the place so let's check
out what happened here as it's really
really a wild game magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with f3 which yes is
diretti opening but we will transpose
into a king's indian defense with knight
f6 c4 now transposing into the english
g6 we have knight to c3 and bishop to g7
magnus hits the center with e4 and now
levon castles we have pawn to d4 by
magnus and we have now transposed into
the king's indian defense we have pawn
to d6 bishop to e2 by magnus and pawn to
e5 now uh magnus castles and now the
incredibly rare move pawn to h6 uh there
are many moves here you can play knight
to c6 a5e captures on v for knight to d7
but h6 has only been played a handful of
times and mostly by
uzbekistan players uh uh i'm pretty sure
you heard of them they have won the
olympiad uh such as vacation and also
adiban has been known to play h6 uh so
here pawn to d5 magnus continues in a
principle manner he just grabs the
center knight b to d7 and now bishop to
e3 uh we have a knight to h7 now
preparing pawn to f5 and here there is a
game where knights the d2 was played as
white also wants to play f4 he doesn't
want to see something like f5 f4 on the
board but here magnus instead goes queen
to d2 and it is now as of move 10 that
we have a completely new game point
being that f5 is now impossible uh
because of bishop captures on h6 at some
point it's attacked twice it's defended
only once but that is exactly why levon
plays it because it is impossible
however only seemingly so here quanta f5
and what is magnus to make of this it's
such a weird move to make uh in this and
an even weirder one to face especially
in this situation in the match magnus is
leading and he only needs a draw to get
a victory in the match uh but he uh well
he's not really known to back down from
a challenge so he goes for it he
captures on f5 g captures in the bishop
captures an h6 a completely destroying
levon's defenses in front of the the
king bishop captures queen captures and
now just a nice rook to f6 attacking
carlson's queen here queen to h4 now if
the rook moves magnus will trade queens
happily but not knight d to f8 with
ideas of attacking the queen even
further so g3 uh we have queen to e7 and
now queen to h5 you could also consider
a move like c5
uh just opening up the the the c file
maybe putting a rook on c1 because if
black ever captures on c5 then the
center will be ruined and of course
levon uh
will not do that but okay it's a move
maybe uh you would consider in a
classical game uh so here just queen to
h5 uh and now how do you continue magnus
is obviously planning to bring the
knight to h4 so queen to g7 and now
knight to h4 level and brings the knight
to g5 and now pawn to f4 so now you
don't have to worry about level 1
executing at f4 at any point
e captures with g captures uh this is a
beautiful move uh allowing lavon all
sorts of nasty discoveries and uh um uh
well there really aren't all that many
great discoveries lavone played knight
to e4 and opened up this discovery but
worth considering uh is also rook to h6
but it doesn't do much uh because here
magnus just captures uh on on g5 and one
captures on h4
and since uh levon needs a win here uh
trying to get some sort of an end game
like this against magnus okay the queens
are obviously going to get traded off at
some point isn't the the way to go so
levon needs to keep complicating even
further knight to e4 opening up this
discovery king to h1 magnus very very
happily opens up the g file for his
rooks and now rook to h6 and this is
where the magic happens uh there are
many moves here that are possible but
magnus goes for knight captures on e4
and he sacrifices his queen and it seems
like okay but of course magnus will just
play rook to g1 he's going to win the
queen back well not really
because after rook captures an h5 which
was played in the game you can't play
rook to g1 if you play rook to g1 then
rook captures on h4 and after rook
captures king captures now if you
counted the material levon is just up a
full rook so
that's not the way to go so magnus plays
bishop captures on h5 this is the only
way to play and now comes queen to h6
getting the queen away from the g file
and now putting pressure on the bishop
and the knight on the h file
and now we have knight to g3 by magnus
now here we are going to discuss uh two
to three
fine lines and of course you guys are
wondering what happens if rook g won
rook g1 is an incredibly complicated
move that requires a lot of calculation
that will win you the pawn or rather a
pawn uh at the end of the line uh point
being that after rook the g1 check king
to h8
there is knights the g6 check offering a
trait of knights and there's really
nothing better so knight captures the
rook captures and now look at this queen
capture sun h5 and now the brilliant
rook the g8 so you have to see all of
this in order to win the uh the the pawn
so king captures and now knight f6 check
will fork the king and queen king of
seven knight captures here and now if
you count the pawns white has six pawns
uh black has five and levon uh will be
uh fighting of course for a draw here
uh but of course he needs a win so uh
that that's not really uh all that
impressive for him but magnus feels he
can do even better or maybe he just
didn't feel like calculating all of this
and he plays knight to g3 he defends his
bishop here and now he's gonna put the
uh rook on g1 maybe the rook on e1 uh
gain control over the e8 square uh and
so on so here we have bishop to d7 uh
hoping to get some bishop to e8 action
in bud magnus says no way rook a to e1
keeping an eye on the e8 square and now
comes pawn to b5 this was also a fine
moment for levon to bring the king over
to h8 as uh well it's just a funny
square for the king but he decides to
push b5 and really put pressure on
magnus's center but now comes pawn to c5
and this is something magnus played very
very quickly as it's a positional idea
and the magnus of course thrives when a
positional idea
needs to be found point is that if black
captures that we are winning the e5
square for our knight just to give you
an example d captures on c5 let's say
rook g1 we threaten some discoveries
king h8 knight f3 now the knight is
coming to f5 then to f7 and that's
pretty much it uh so instead we have
queen to f6 not going for this capture
and now knight to f3 uh always a useful
square for tonight in the future you can
go to e5 or g5 if black ever decides to
capture here and now how do you continue
uh
to play this uh in the game d captures
and c5 was played but let's say knight
to h7 is played um you can't really
allow c6 c6 is too strong and that's why
i believe levon captured now you go
bishop back to see it now the rook no
longer has control over the back rank
you play rook g1 threaten some nasty
discoveries if king h8 rook to e8 with
the check and there's just no move that
black can make here it's it's a
disgusting position
so after knight to f3 d captures on c5
it's not a good move but it's a move so
rook to g1 now again threatening nasty
discoveries and king to h8 levon gets
out of the way knights the e5 occupying
the the uh
square that
has just been made available for the
knight and king to h7 avoiding any nasty
checks here so bishop to f7 by magnus uh
very very an a nice move uh now even
ideas like bishop the g8 check will be
possible the king will have to go in
front of the rook or maybe not maybe the
h8 but then again you have all sorts of
nasty checks available now comes bishop
to e8 as the knight is on e5 lemon can
finally make use of this bishop and now
magnus plays bishop captures on e8 now
this was due to magnus being low on time
and magnus only needs to draw this game
to get a win so he can't really push
everything um
into this game to get a win but i will
show you a fun line uh that starts with
bishop the g8 with check now of course
you cannot capture otherwise knight h5
check just picks up the queen so king h8
and now rook to e3 preparing to move the
knight and then bring the rook over to
h3 and with the rook being on g1
that's pretty much it black can find
some very nice defensive ideas but after
let's say knight h5 attacking the queen
queen h4 the only good move rook
captures on g6 queen captures on h5 rook
to g1 uh now uh whatever you play it
doesn't really matter for example okay
not queen h3 obviously but let's say
queen h4
now you play bishop to f7 again now you
are threatening knight
g6 check to win the queen so here we
would have a trade knight captures with
czech king h7 and now rookie the g3 and
uh there is no defense against rook to
g7 checkmate so it's uh it's a one of
the lines that are possible but it's one
that i thought you guys would enjoy uh
so bishop g8 uh and regardless of how
black plays this is winning for white
but magnus played bishop capture sun e8
rook captures and now comes rook to e3
so still the correct idea the rook will
come to h3 and uh it doesn't seem like
black can survive this so knight to g6
and now magnus needs to find the move
there are some moves that are winning
here and there are some moves that
aren't winning so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find those that
are as maybe the move in the game is not
a winning one that was played so have at
it have a few seconds or as much as you
like it's your time and your you know
a computer or a device so you know
use it wisely
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
knight must be moved right away to e2 or
to e4 you can play knight e2 and you can
play knights to e4 both of both work
knight d4 i i believe is cooler as you
put the knight in front of the pawn so i
always you know prefer the the cooler
move to be played point being now that
uh well uh what would you play with
black rook to h3 is coming and then
that's just it rooked h3 check rook
captures here will end the game so you
have to capture some material but still
rook h3 check king to g7 and not rook h2
g3 uh and there is no defense against
this and also i i forgot to mention
congratulations to everyone who spotted
this idea uh you are you are uh well uh
a perhaps a better uh player at magnus
but only when you are in your own home
and the magnus is playing lavon arunian
so rook captures on e5 let's say you
have to play something and now we just
trade down into a king and pawn end game
which is funny as there's so much
material on the board queen captures
rook captures king captures pawn
captures and uh with the two pawns
controlling all of this you will be
winning and you don't have to worry
about these pawns because you can easily
catch up to them for example c4 king g2
b4 you're gonna play king f2 c3 yes
black creates a past pawn but now king
e3 and you are in the square of the pawn
you uh have nothing to worry about and
the pawns are just winning here so after
knight to g6 this was of course possible
but magnus decided to play knight stay
h5 and levon finds a brilliancy here
that saves him the game queen to h4
we have knight captures and g6 by magnus
and now queen captures on h5 now the
rook is hanging but if magnus captures
the rook then he allows queen to f3
check and there really isn't a good way
to stop this so he played rook capture
78 queen to f3 with check rook to g2
queen d1 check
rook to g1 and queen captures on d5 with
check and now you can't move the king
you have to block with the rook and now
again
of course queen d1 check rook to g1
queen to f3 check uh rook the g2 and
queen f1 check rook g1 queen f3 rook g2
queen to d1 check rook to g1 and queen
to d5 with check uh levon cannot play
this as the two rooks and the knight are
just uh
much much stronger also rook to h8 looks
uh incredibly impressive so after rook
to g2 levon delivered one more check and
he was in this position that magnus and
lebron agreed to a draw or rather it
would it was a draw by a three-fold
repetition
so really really an incredible game uh
beautiful uh positional uh queen
sacrificed by magnus and there were so
many cool variations especially the one
uh that uh we discussed here with bishop
the g8 uh but of course uh
uh it's all about winning the match so
magnus could not afford um you know he
he was a very low on time i think he was
below the one minute mark and you know
just spending those extra seconds just
to find the brilliancy
and then ruin your match uh of course
that will not happen uh but impressive
game by both of them the lavon uh had to
play actively he had to play the king's
indian defense a beautiful beautiful
pawn sacrifice by lavone this was really
really awesome here uh
just you know going for this knight to
h7 f5 idea with the idea of giving up
the h6 pawn really really cool uh but in
the end magnus did
what he does best and he converted his
advantage he didn't win the game but he
won the match uh so yeah that's the game
and the match hope you guys enjoyed it
magnus has now three wins in row and i
know what you guys are uh thinking what
uh what about the other guy who has two
wins in a row and now has played a third
match against hans mok and eman of
course i'm talking about pragnanda
we are going to discuss that in the next
video as that game is also or those
games are also very very impressive uh
so yeah and once again really hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
ricky mini uh excellent subscriber
brendan ward uh johan clayson and
raymond raphael for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the ftx
crypto cup uh until it finishes uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day